i think they really need for someone to
be pam
really i mean i tried to explain to them
that pam's not actually
i think uh i think we gotta give them
what they want jim uh
jim you gotta kiss pam
wow thank you john krasinski we didn't
know we needed this
uh i got a question okay yeah
kiss pam all right none of these things
are really questions though are they
uh i need you to kiss pam that is what i
need to see
today saturday night live aired their
first episode of 2021
and the office star locking lips with
pete davidson was just one of the
highlights
i think we got to give them what they
want jim
you gotta kiss pam
it was the 41 year old actor's first
time hosting the iconic comedy series
i'm excited to see it too and he had
help from musical guest machine gun
kelly
who was also making his snl debut you
might be the only thing in america that
still works
yeah so i guess everyone must be rooting
for you right
almost no one krazynski kicked off the
show with an impersonation of another
famous bostonian
tom brady well you know what i'll be
rooting for you tom brady because
you're the only goddamn thing this
country can still rely on
and it's not like you're a weird trump
guy or anything right
thanks for having me
brady is one of the most accomplished
nfl players of all time
and for the first time as a tampa bay
buccaneer he's about to play in his 10th
super bowl championship on sunday
once again machine gun kelly and in
between the laughs
mgk got emotional in his music numbers
[Music]
[Music]
social media praised the 30 year old
singer's performances
in particular his second song lonely
which has
lyrics tied to his father's death last
[Music]
year
and leading up to the show mgk was seen
around new york with girlfriend megan
fox
who maybe held her breath when this
moment happened at the end of the
[Applause]
episode
yep while having some fun with davidson
during the show's goodbyes
mgk fell off the snl stage
what a way to bounce back krazynski was
originally set to make his hosting debut
in march of 2020 but it got postponed
after the onset of the coronavirus
pandemic
snl he chatted with e.t
weeks before his initial appearance
where he gushed over how much he loves
the long running series
first time oh man i'm having a real
existential conversation with my
eight-year-old self who
uh stole a tv from the basement to watch
snl since eight years old so
i'm talking to him in my head right now
and we're trying to work it out yeah
nervous in comparison for part two
versus
oh my god i think snl takes the cake
yeah yeah i am
i'm almost throwing up thinking about it
don't do it john okay cool thank you
thank you
[Music]
you